The solutions were negative 3 halves, and 1 6th. Nice work if you found both of
these. You've really mastered factoring if you got these correct. If this gave
you some trouble, you definitely want to review your factoring techniques, and
try solving some quadratic equations on your own. We start factoring by finding
the factor pair of negative 36 that sums to positive 16. Those two factors are
negative 2 and 18. We use these as the coefficients of x to rewrite this middle
term. Then we use factoring by grouping to get 2 x plus 3 times 6 x minus 1.
Next, we set each of these factors equal to 0. We solve each equation for x to
get x is equal to negative 3 halves, and x is equal to 1 6th. This is our
solution set.